parents families friends welcome to the
309 'the immense minh l university we
gather to recognize the extraordinary
accomplishments of all you who have
worked so hard to complete your programs
of study we salute your effort your
diligence your talent and your intellect
we also join you in expressing gratitude
for all who have supported you in these
endeavors your families friends teachers
and other members of the Yale community
in keeping with the tradition of this
occasion I now call upon the chaplain to
offer an invocation my sisters and my
brothers let us pray Almighty God source
of all truth here we stand in the
splendor of this morning many
expressions of one living mystery which
is beyond all telling as students of
your handiwork we have gathered from all
parts of your world with exquisite
ambitions and have been blessed at this
place of truth and light with the
freedom to let them grow you walk with
us when we stumble and when we soar as
we pause here embraced by this moment we
are grateful for our beloved families
and friends yet we are mindful of those
dear ones who are not here and they are
deeply missed our God of all generations
you are the guardian of where we are
going and who we are becoming you have
called us to lovingly shape this
beautiful yet aching world we are
humbled but ready now we ask you bless
our hands with tenderness for all that
we touch bless our lips with wise words
we may speak in healing ways bless our
eyes with an impassioned vision so we
are never blind to possibility and bless
our hearing so we may be open to all
understanding
from this moment on infuse our hearts
with an imaginative daring one that
stirs us to become living vibrant
examples of Shalom of Salaam of Shanti
of peace for this we say Amen
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for the bachelor's
degrees in Yale College for the degree
of Bachelor of Arts 1047 in number and
for the degree of Bachelor of Science
232 in number they have been recommended
by the Faculty of Yale College and
approved by the corporation I now ask
you by your official act to confer upon
them these degrees
by the authority vested in me I confer
upon you the bachelors degrees in Yale
College as designated by the Dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
mr. president I have the honor to
announce the winner of prizes in Yale
College which were conferred at class
day exercises yesterday the Lewis sutler
prize for excellence in the arts is
awarded this year to Lucy
hazel Fitzgibbon of Timothy Dwight
College the Warren Memorial High
scholarship prize is awarded to the
senior majoring in the humanities who
ranks highest in scholarship the Arthur
twining Hadley Prize is awarded to the
senior and Yale College majoring in the
social sciences who ranks highest in
scholarship this year both prizes are
awarded to meet hon Robin Lee of Sabre
College
the Russell the Russell Henry Chittenden
prize is awarded to that senior in Yale
College majoring in the Natural Sciences
or in mathematic - ranked highest in
scholarship this year's prize is awarded
to Susan Elizabeth Scanlon of Timothy
Dwight college and the Alphaeus Henry
snow prize is awarded to that senior who
through the combination of intellectual
achievement character and personality
shall be adjudged by the faculty to have
done the most for Yale by inspiring in
his or her classmates and admiration and
love for the best traditions of high
scholarship this year the snow prize is
awarded to Elias Fung and Bildner of
Davenport College
I congratulate you for the extraordinary
achievement which is represented by
these awards for the contribution that
you have made to your to your University
and for the promise which your
accomplishments hold for the life and
times of your generation congratulations
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Architecture
small but noticeable for the degree of
Master of Architecture sixty-five in
number for the degree of Master of
Environmental Design four in number they
have been recommended they have been
recommended by the Faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation I now
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them these degrees by the authority
vested in me I confer upon you the
degrees in architecture and design as
designated by the Dean and admit you to
all their rights and responsibilities
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
school of art for the degree of Master
of Fine Arts 54 in number they have been
recommended by the Faculty of the school
of art and approved by the corporation I
now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them this degree by the
authority vested in me I confer upon you
the degree in art as designated by the
Dean and admit you to all its rights and
responsibilities
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Drama
for the degree of Master of Fine Arts 57
in number and for the degree of Doctor
of Fine Arts 1 in number they have been
recommended by the Faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation I now
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them these degrees by the authority
vested in me I confer upon you the
degrees in drama as designated by the
Dean and admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities mr. president I
have the honor to present candidates for
degrees in the School of Music for the
certificate in performance 3 and number
4 the artists diploma 25 at number 4 the
degree Master of Music 79 in number 4
the degree Master of Musical Arts 6 in
number and for the degree Doctor of
Musical Arts 6 in number they have been
recommended by the Faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation I now
ask you by your official act to confer
upon them these degrees by the authority
vested in me I confer upon you the
degrees in music as designated by the
Dean and admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Nursing
for the certificate in nursing 79 in
number for the postmasters certificate
in nursing 2 in number for the degree of
Master of Science in Nursing 108 in
number and for the degree of Doctor of
Nursing science 2 in number they have
been recommended by the Faculty of the
school and approved by the corporation I
now ask you by your official act to
confer upon them these degrees by the
authority vested in me I confer upon you
the degrees in nursing as designated by
the Dean and admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Forestry in environmental
studies
for the degree for the degree of Master
of Forestry 12 in number for the degree
of Master of forest science 7 in number
for the degree of Master of
Environmental Management 76 in number
for the degree of Master of
Environmental Science 40 in number they
have been recommended by the Faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degrees in forestry
and environmental studies as designated
by the Dean and admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Management
for the degree for the degree of Masters
of Business Administration 207 in number
they have been recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them this
degree by the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degree in management
as designated by the Dean and admit you
to all its rights and responsibilities
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
Divinity School
for the degree of Master of Arts in
religion 69 in number for the degree of
Master of Divinity 51 in number and for
the degree of Master of sacred theology
12 in number they have been recommended
by the Faculty of the school and
approved by the corporation I now ask
you by your official act to confer upon
them these degrees by the authority
vested in me I confer upon you the
degrees in religion divinity and
theology as designated by the Dean and
admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
mr. president and have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
law school
for the degree of Master of studies in
law one in number for the degree of
Juris Doctor 196 in number for the
degree of Master of Laws 23 in number
for the degree of the doctor of the
science of law 2 in number when they
have been recommended by the Faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation I shall ask you by your
official act to confer upon them their
degrees by the authority vested in me I
shall confer upon you the degrees in the
law school when designated by the Dean
and shall then admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
graduate school for the degree of Master
of Science 151 in number for the degree
of Master of Arts 287 in number for the
degree of Master of Philosophy 319 in
number they have been recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees but the authority vested in me I
confer upon you the degrees in the
graduate school as designated by the
Dean and admit you to all their rights
and responsibilities
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Public Health for the degree
of Master of Public Health 108 in number
they they have been recommended by the
faculty and approved by the corporation
I now ask you by your official act to
grant upon them these degrees by the
authority vested in me I confer upon you
the degree in public health as
designated by the Dean and admit you to
all its rights and responsibilities
mr. president I have the honor to
present candidates for degrees in the
School of Medicine
for the degree of Master of Medical
Science 36 in number but when they have
been recommended by the Faculty of the
school and approved by the corporation I
shall ask you by your official act to
confer upon them this degree for the
degree of Master of health science 23 in
number and and for the degree of Doctor
of Medicine 109 in number
that they have been recommended by the
Faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation I now ask you by your
official act to confer upon them these
degrees by the authority vested in me I
shall confer the degree in medical
science and do confer upon you the
degrees in health science and medicine
as designated by the Dean and admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
priceless Clarisse emai Conde de
nostradame
Candida know that branham's philosophy a
doctoress número crescendo septuagint a
duo timey presento a faculty a
philosophy I am Kwai Bob Senado
Academical illustrate a pro bodysuits
teh dominate Bravo
hotels at home kratom admit us secundum
legis more employ universitatis NOS try
wasps at Groton philosophy I doctors
admit oh whoa this way
there's more
well be square you know come hope
diplomat a euro
illa aqua dignity at ease why odd
hongcun or inspectin conferral nuke
studious delicate air absolute ease a go
prices university at ease
most animal ebay Oh Salwa ra8 while a
ray
inside
please be seated we now proceed to the
awarding of honorary degrees the 10 men
and women we honor this morning serve as
examples to you our graduates to
encourage you to aspire to excellence to
value those elements of human character
that they embody creativity curiosity
discipline integrity and a passion for
social justice their presence here also
honors you who graduate today and all of
us who are here to salute you
I will now as this customary call upon
the Provost to present the candidates
for honorary degrees mr. president I
have the honor to present the candidates
for honorary degrees for the degree of
Doctor of humanities Robert altar
scholar
as a scholar of comparative literature
you're thoughtful and brilliant work
ranges from studies of the English and
European novel to questions of tradition
and modernity to trends in American and
Jewish culture but the greatest gifts
you have given us are your unparalleled
translation and your interpretations of
the Hebrew Bible by combining a poetic
ear with intellectual rigor you have
illuminating illuminated the meaning of
these ancient sacred texts in a fresh
voice that is faithful to their origins
celebrating the beauty and inspiration
of your work we are pleased to confer
the degree of Doctor of humanities
for the degree of Doctor of Laws Ellen
Johnson Sirleaf president of the
Republic of Liberia
as an advocate for reform and as the
first woman elected as head of state in
an African country
you are an inspiration arrested for
challenging the ruling powers you
persevered to run for office fight
corruption and bring integrity to
government popular with your people and
principled in your politics you have
promoted economic development improved
health restored civility and kept peace
your vision of a renewed Liberia is
becoming a reality because of your
sacrifice dedication determination and
wisdom we are greatly honored to bestow
upon you the degree of Doctor of Laws
for the degree of doctor of Medical
Sciences Michael Rutter child
psychiatrist
widely acclaimed as the father of child
psychiatry your pioneering work has
powerfully advanced our understanding of
the mental health social development and
resilience of children and adolescence
your seminal studies of the effects of
disrupted maternal interaction and the
emotional mechanisms for coping with
stress have transformed the way we view
child development you have taken
children seriously examining behavior
through the complex interaction of
environment interpersonal relationships
genes neurobiology and schooling for
your intellectual curiosity your
groundbreaking research and your
contributions to the well-being of
children we are proud to name you doctor
of Medical Science
for the degree of Doctor of Humane
Letters Michael Feinberg and David Levin
educators
you are educational entrepreneurs and
visionaries your creation the knowledge
is power program has helped poor
children achieve impressive academic
success with more than 80 Kip schools
now serving over 21,000 students in 19
states you are showing how classrooms
can be transformed and how the promise
of public education can be fulfilled you
practice what you teach work hard
be nice we are pleased to award you
Michael
your first Yale degree and to welcome
you home David for a second one Doctor
of Humane Letters
for the degree of Doctor of Fine Arts
John emo filmmaker and choreographer
a genius with camera and choreography
your work has portrayed China in all its
glory complexity contradiction and charm
in films that explore triumph and
oppression history and hope you have
captured the struggles of the human
spirit and engaged and enlightened
audiences around the globe from film to
opera to live performance your artistry
amazes and entertains the dazzling
opening ceremony of the Beijing Olympic
Games your epic salute to Chinese
history and culture endures vividly in
our memory we are delighted to bestow on
you this degree of Doctor of Fine Arts
for the degree of Doctor of Social
Sciences Maryland Strathearn
anthropologist your research has had a
seminal influence on the field of Social
Anthropology from your studies of gender
and Melanesia to your work on kinship in
England you have made fundamentals
substantive and methodological advances
you are an intellectual intellectual
admired by your students respected by
your colleagues you are a teacher of
uncompromising standards and as the head
of Girton College an exemplary citizen
of Cambridge University for your
contributions to our understanding of
the human family we name you doctor of
social sciences
for the degree of Doctor of Letters
Orhan Pamuk novelist you have helped to
give new life to the novel one that
weaves together past and present
modernity and history national and
cosmopolitan secular and religious your
stories are rich and multi-layered
complex and at times mystical your
writing bridges the themes of east and
west
tackling issues and moral questions
faced by thoughtful people in Turkey and
around the globe the world has honored
you with countless devoted readers and a
Nobel Prize we add our acclaim with the
degree of Doctor of Letters
for the degree of doctor of music Aretha
Franklin vocalist
we know royalty when we see it and you
are without question the Queen of Soul a
natural woman you have been singing your
whole life learning the grace of gospel
from family and faith community tuning
it with your own sometimes painful often
joyful experiences and creating a
signature style that transcends any one
musical genre you have sung the nation's
hopes at presidential inaugurations and
shared your gifts with generations of
music lovers from gospel to pop from
blues to hip-hop your voice expresses
our feelings with the greatest RESP ECT
we name you doctor of music
for the degree of Doctor of Science
Steven Chu scientist and public servant
as an experimental physicist you
accomplish the seemingly impossible by
trapping and cooling atoms with beams of
light now you are confronting another
formidable challenge transforming
national energy policy you are promoting
new technologies that will reduce our
dependence on foreign oil and even more
significantly overcome the dangers of
global warming as a community of
scholars we take immense pride that a
Nobel laureate and physicist is serving
the nation at such a critical time and
we are delighted to honor you with the
degree of Doctor of Science
let us pray may the gracious one who has
brought us to this joyous and glorious
day guard us and guide us as we go forth
inspiring us to turn our learning into
lives dedicated to the service of truth
and goodness of light and peace and of
justice for all amen